the u.s is getting ready to receive
thousands of ukrainian refugees
according to the white house and many
could be heading here to our state
that's right it's a process we've seen
before now a local immigration attorney
says while the concept of aid is great
the outcome can be tricky
i think the u.s should should always
help alyssa cooley with unlv's
immigration clinic says the recent
announcement to welcome thousands of
ukrainian refugees in the u.s is
humanitarian but the process she says is
not new especially for nevada
afghanistan for example
there there were
evacuees from from that country just
last year um in the united states did
about four months later announced that
they would accept refugees
and nevada received about
150 to 160. coulee says the announcement
also stated those refugees have families
across america which would help in their
resettlement transition in some cases
they can get employment authorization
but not always and
as an immigration attorney um with
experience filing work permit
applications based on parole it can take
anywhere from eight
ten eleven months at this time it's
unclear how many ukrainians would come
to nevada but cooley says organizations
like catholic charities are crucial with
things like food shelter and clothing
temporary aid she says that many
struggle to hold on to there is a
massive backlog i think i read that the
that uscis currently has over 400 000
applications pending
well in 2020 catholic charities helped
welcome about 700 refugees to nevada now
their goal they say is to help each of
them become self-sufficient and
independent as quickly as possible